hi there steve kaufman here
um one of the uh i guess common themes
here at uh my
video uh my channel here youtube and
also on my blog is the
rather spectacular lack of success of
formal language instruction in schools
and we spend a lot of time
and a lot of money on instructing kids
in languages at school
and certainly here in canada
english-speaking school children very
few of them end up being able to speak
french although they all have to take
french
in a previous video i talked about the
experience in japan where
kids spend i don't know how many hours
on english
and they don't
learn very well those that learn well
are the ones that are motivated and
learn on their own
uh and i've sort of come to the
conclusion that the biggest problem the
biggest reason why if we had to find one
reason why kids have a tough time with
language learning at school i would say
it's because of the tests and i include
in tests all kinds of exercises tests
wherever the teacher tries to test the
knowledge of the learner
you know those kids that have their
first experience with acquiring another
language or learning another language
outside the school system either from
their mother if say the
mother speaks a different language from
the father or because they move to a
different country
those kids learn very well and they end
up very often speaking another language
whereas the ones that
encounter the language in a in a school
setting i end up not speaking very well
at all
and you know i looked at some of the
comments i had in japan about the kinds
of things they do
in class where they decode texts and and
of course i had a comment from one of my
uh viewers who is a teacher in japan who
explained that they have to do such
things as write out
um you know the same word 400 times but
all because they're trying to learn
these words for a specific test so
everything is geared around the test so
they make the kids do things that are
ridiculous
like writing words out 400 times
specifically for the test
um you know and i look at my uh
my granddaughter who had to recite a
poem now there again it's not for a test
but it was a poem that she wasn't
interested in it wasn't a very
interesting poem she was there trying to
memorize it so that the next day should
repeat it in class in other words the
teacher is looking for some
demonstration
that the kids have learned
and then we contrast that with the
example i gave of the teacher in algeria
who had his students
learn the words of popular songs like
the beatles
and i've heard that kind of thing before
i was
again at this french language meetup
there was another lady there vancouver
anglophone who spoke english spoke
french very well and i asked her why she
did so well and she said well we had
so-and-so as a teacher in such and such
a school and everybody knows that
whoever had so and so
they all learned to speak french well
well i said what did she do well she got
us interested in the you know
felix le claire and and some of the you
know well-known singers from quebec
uh
no that meant everybody's taste but she
managed to make that interesting so she
made it interesting for her students so
you know i get back this thing there are
so many tools available today
if we forget about testing the kids
if the objective is like how do we make
it fun how do we make sure that they
spend time with the language and some
will do better and some will do worse
we
we just have to find something that
turns the crank
and i've mentioned this before when i
described how i would run a classroom i
would let them read in class i would let
them read and and i would give them you
know everyone i really have to say i
think this the ipod and maybe there's
other brand names that are just as good
but the ipod touch is just an amazing
tool
it's an amazing tool because you can put
so much in the way of learning resources
dictionaries texts
flash card system you name it into this
little device and we're only just
beginning and if this cost two hundred
dollars every kid should get one because
it costs the school system
something like seven thousand dollars to
put each kid through
school per year
so buying them one of these things if
they don't already have them is a
relatively small amount of money
compared to the amount that is wasted
uh largely through this uh school system
with all the excessive bureaucracy and
meetings and professional professional
days for the teachers and all the rest
of it
and i would have them reading class
and i've been reading now myself i've
been reading uh in italian
uh using the dictionary that i have on
on my ipod
and then i collect all and of course it
collects in a list and then i take that
list of words and i punch it all into
link so that as i load up more content
on link all of these words are already
in my database highlighted in yellow and
so forth and so on it's delightful and
it's fun to do it's fun to sit there and
look things up in the dictionary so i
would have them doing that i would
expose them to things of interest i mean
obviously you'd have to mix up
some freedom of choice to for them to
listen to things that they want to do
and some things you'd have to do in
common so that in class you could talk
about it i would have them as i've said
before i would have the kids
select their favorite words and phrases
from their listening and reading and
maybe
talk about them in class initially in in
their own language
and eventually uh if if some are ready
for it to talk in the target language
but it doesn't have to be that
i think it should just be a matter of of
getting them somehow hoping to get them
turned on to the language because
there's one thing that's for sure and
that is that the present system with the
emphasis on testing and testing trying
to prove that they've learned what we
taught them
and and doing that year after year
uh when we see that in the end the
result is that very few of them can
speak the language at least in the case
of english canada
and in japan
only the very motivated learn
i think the system is the situation is
different in certain countries in europe
not in southern europe uh to judge from
my discussions with albert in barcelona
and with alberto in italy
uh the situation there is the same as in
canada and japan
now in sweden the situation is different
but i think that has nothing to do with
the amount of testing to do at school
and has everything to do with the fact
that
so many television programs are
available in english and the the kids
there are exposed to english-speaking
culture whether from england or from the
united states
uh you know as as early uh you know in
in their childhood and they're exposed
to english-speaking pop culture and
whatever it might be so
the message here is you know the more i
think of it i i'm just convinced that
that is test you know this desire
it's not as like let's face it language
learning in ours if i take the case of
english-speaking canadians
we basically assume the kids are not
gonna are not gonna learn to speak
french i mean let's let's get serious
uh
for the last i'm you know 64
uh you know for at least 50 years nobody
learns french at school so that it's
basically a given that they're not going
to learn through this pro through this
process so i think we can afford to
experiment a little and having seen the
results of the japanese english speaking
instruction uh program
you know i i think there should be some
room for for experimentation because
what what's happening right now doesn't
work it's like
it's not doing the job i mean that's a
given i think learning these languages
almost becomes like a luxury it's
something that's on the program and we
kind of have to do it but nobody really
expects anybody to learn
we do expect people to learn how to add
and subtract we do expect people to
learn how to read and write
obviously people who want to study
science and so forth they have to learn
certain
you know the foundations of those of
those disciplines in math and physics
but in language that doesn't matter the
foundations don't matter
you can learn
certain vocabulary or or certain
basic structures later there i don't
believe that it's that language is a
matter of building creating a foundation
and building on that foundation i'm
totally uh convinced that that's not the
case at all it's it's more like a a
crossword puzzle that as you put more
pieces in there it starts to become
clearer gradually and you don't know at
what point certain things are going to
become clear and it's only through this
through this exposure so
if we can somehow interest kids in the
language
and let them just acquire words and
familiarity with the language
they can't do worse than what's
happening right now
so
they're
as i say i think we should get rid of
tests in the school system and so far as
language instruction is concerned gone
none period i think we'll get better
results
okay thanks for listening